let's all leak code one to some the most
popular leak code question so we're
given an input array and some target in
this case 9 and we want to find the two
values in this input array that sum to 9
so in this case it's 2 & 7 now we want
to return the indices of these two
values so the index of zero of the index
of two is zero the index of 7 is 1 so we
return 0 & 1
we're guaranteed that there's exactly
one solution so we don't have to worry
about not finding a solution and we
don't have to worry about multiple
solutions now the most intuitive way to
solve this problem is basically just
check every combination of two values
and see if they can sum up to our target
so we start at 2 we check every
combination we can make that includes 2
so we scan through the remainder of the
array 1 5 3 and check if any of those
numbers added to 2 some store target for
in this case none of them do so next we
can repeat the process
let's check every combination including
one that sums up the target for so we
scan through every element that comes
after at 5 & 3 and we find that one
added with 3 sums up to our target 4
notice that we didn't have to check the
values that came before 1 because we
already checked the combination 2 & 1
when we were up over here remember when
we checked every combination with 2 so
we didn't have to repeat that work down
here we only had to check the numbers
that came after 1
so the runtime of this algorithm isn't
super efficient this is basically brute
force we're going through the entire
array of length and and we're gonna do
that worst case n times for each number
this means that over all worst case time
complexity will be O of N squared so can
we do better now the thing to notice is
that for each number for example 1 the
value we're looking for is the
difference between the target and this
value 1 so we're looking for 4 minus 1
which is equal to 3 so that means this
is the only value we can add to one
that'll equal the target so we don't
have to check every number we just want
to know if
resist s-- now the easiest way we can do
this the most efficient is by making a
hash map of every value in our input
array so we can instantly check if the
value 3 exists now let's try the same
problem except let's use a hash map this
time now in our hash map we're going to
be mapping each value to the index of
each value so the index of 2 is 0 the
index of 1 is 1 the index of 5 is 2 the
index of 3 is 3 so let's so in our hash
map we're going to be mapping the value
to the index
now we could add every value in this
array into the hash map before we start
iterating through it but there's
actually an easier way to do it if we
added the entire array into the hash map
initially then we would get to the value
2 first right we would want to checked
as the difference between target 4 minus
this value 2 which is equal to 2 exists
in our hash map and we would find that 2
does exist in our hash map but we're not
allowed to reuse the same one right
because they're both at the same index
we can't use the same value twice so we
would have to compare the index of our
current 2 with the index of the 2 that's
in our hash map there's actually an
easier way to do this though and it's a
little clever and let me show you how to
do it that way so doing it this clever
way initially we say our hash map is
empty so we get to the value 2 first of
all right and we want to look for the
difference 4 minus 2 in our hash map our
hash map is empty so we don't find 2 so
then after we visited this element then
we can add it to our hash map so now
that I'm done visiting it I'm gonna move
to the second element 1 and before I do
that I'm gonna add this value 2 to our
hash map and the index of this value is
gonna be 0 now I'm at 1 I'm looking for
4 minus 1 which is 3
I see 3 isn't in our hash map but it
actually is in our array so what's the
problem well for now we're going to say
we don't find our find
three so we add one to our hash map the
index of this one is one and now we move
to the next element five we check does
four minus five it's four minus five
exists in our hash map that's negative
one so no it does not then we add this
five to our hash map and it's index
which is two and we move to the last
value in the array three we checked this
four minus three e
exists in our hash map now that's one so
we see it does exist right right over
here it exists the value exists and it's
index is one so now we found our two
values that sum to the target and we
want to return their indexes their
indices which are going to be one and
three so with this algorithm we don't
have to initialize our hash map it can
be initially empty and then we can just
iterate through this array in one pass
now the reason the algorithm can work in
that way with just one pass is this so
let's say we had a giant array right we
know for sure that there are two
elements in this array that sum to our
target right we don't know where they
are they're at some arbitrary location
when we visit the first one of those
elements our hash map is only going to
be this portion of the array it's only
going to have the values that came
before the first value so we're gonna
we're gonna notice that the second value
that can sum to the target is no is not
going to be in our hash map yet but once
we get to the second value our hash map
is going to be this portion so every
value that comes before this right so
we're gonna be guaranteed that once we
visit the second element that sums up to
the target we're gonna be guaranteed
that the first one is already in our
hash map so we're guaranteed to find the
solution now since we only have to
iterate through the array once and we're
adding each value to our hash map which
is a constant time operation and we're
checking if a value exists in our hash
which is also a constant time operation
the time complexity is going to be Big O
of n we are using extra memory right
that hash map isn't free so the memory
complexity is also going to be O of n
because we could potentially add every
value to the hash map
so now let's code the solution so
remember we need a hash map right I'm
going to call this previous map because
it's basically every element that comes
before the current home that every
previous element is going to be stored
in this map where it can be mapping the
value to the index of that value
so now let's iterate through every value
in this array we need the index as well
as the actual number so let's do it like
this and Python before we add this to
our map let's check if the difference
which is equal to target minus n now
let's check if this difference is
already in the hash map if it is then we
can return the solution which is going
to be a pair of the indices so I can get
the first index like this and the second
index is just AI now if we don't find
the solution then we have to update our
hash map so for this value n I'm gonna
say the index is I and then we're going
to continue since we're guaranteed that
a solution exists we don't have to
return anything out here right but I'll
just put a return for no reason now
let's see if it works and it works
perfectly so with this kind of neat
little trick but just doing it in one
pass you can reduce the amount of code
you have to write and not have to worry
about like edge cases and comparisons
and things like that